spent all my time in England as a kid
and we used to get into [__] fights
my cousins and his friends they were
just like the fights were nuts pubs
would close at 11:00 which was insane at
10:30 like you have a half hour to get
as drunk as you want people go up there
and be like can I get full points full
shots and so people would get [__]
loaded and then that 11:00 p.m. exit was
like all of a sudden the liquor was kind
of hitting everybody and one of the guys
I was with took a pint glass that he
stole from the pub and to four four or
five dudes walking in front of us he
threw it and it just smashed in front of
them so we all went to this little bus
depot and started like kind of mixing it
up one of my buddies just comes out and
he's been [__] stabbed like right in
his abdomen and he was just gushing
blood so an ambulance came they said he
was like 30 seconds away from dying and
then I went and visited him in the
hospital and he showed my cousin and I
and I passed out and so I woke up in the
hospital like on a couch like huh and
they were like yeah so listen you're
like a huge [__] this guy like